[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ihr habt euch ja einfach Nudelrezepte gewünscht.
Und, was ich bei unserem Italiener supergerne esse, ist
Penne all’arrabbiata!
Also Penne, Penne-Nudeln,
mit einer richtig leckeren scharfen Tomatensoße.
Die Zubereitung ist im Prinzip supereinfach.
Ich zeige es euch trotzdem.
Denn viele haben sich das Rezept gewünscht.
Hier habe ich jetzt die Zutaten in doppelter Menge,
weil wir gleich im gesamten Team essen.
Ich habe auch noch Couscous-Pfanne von gestern.
Das heißt, das wird jetzt unser leckeres Mittagessen.
Da drüben steht Volkan,
macht gerade den Salat.
Hi, Volkan!
>> VOLKAN: Hi!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Gleich wird nämlich hier gemeinsam gegessen.
Und das Gericht ist echt supereinfach,
die Zutaten überschaubar
und ich habe sie auch immer zu Hause.
Weil jetzt gerade noch keine Tomatensaison ist,
greife ich auf Dosentomaten zurück.
Da solltet ihr auch wirklich darauf zurückgreifen
und im Winter keine Tomaten kaufen,
nur zur Saison.
Zum einen sind sie aromatischer
und zum anderen einfach keine Importware.
Hier habe ich
Penne-Nudeln,
Olivenöl,
Knoblauch und Zwiebeln,
eine scharfe Chilischote,
Tomaten aus der Dose,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Und später nehme ich noch etwas Petersilie
und noch Parmesan zum Bestreuen.
Das Nudelwasser habe ich schon aufgesetzt,
also einfach Wasser in einem großen Topf.
Das darf gleich schon kochen.
Hier habe ich einen Topf für die Soße
und kann mein Olivenöl darin erhitzen.
Die Zwiebeln und Knoblauchzehen einfach fein würfeln.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommen die Zwiebelwürfel mit den Knoblauchscheiben
ins Olivenöl und werden einfach für drei bis vier Minuten
schön glasig angebraten.
Ich nehme jetzt hier eine frische Chilischote.
Ihr könnt aber auch,
wenn ihr möchtet,
einfach Chilipulver nehmen
und auch einfach so dazu geben,
so scharf, wie ihr es eben haben möchtet.
Ich mache jetzt hier ein bisschen was von der Spitze dazu,
erst mal nicht zu viel.
Denn ich weiß noch nicht, wie scharf sie ist.
Okay. Ich nehme ein bisschen weniger.
Denn wir haben einige im Team,
die nicht so scharf essen.
Also machen wir es mal so.
Hier den Deckel drauf,
so drei, vier Minuten etwa anbraten.
Und
dann helfe ich Volkan solange
mit dem Salat.
[Musik]
So.
Perfekt sieht das hier aus!
Da kommen jetzt die Tomaten dazu.
Das Ganze würze ich jetzt im Prinzip
auch nur noch mit Salz und Pfeffer.
Pfeffer ist groß.
Salat ist auch gleich soweit.
Hier jetzt die Soße, die darf jetzt hier
so etwa fünf Minuten köcheln.
Und die Zeit nutze ich jetzt auch, um
die Nudeln zu kochen.
Und nicht ganz al dente kochen,
sondern eher noch sehr, sehr, sehr bissfest lassen.
Also ich koche sie jetzt nur etwa fünf Minuten.
Und die restliche Zeit
dürfen sie dann nämlich in der Soße noch köcheln.
So.
Hier kommt jetzt Salz rein.
Die Nudeln kommen hier rein.
Und ich stelle das Ganze jetzt hier auf
fünf Minuten.
[Musik]
Die Nudeln sind jetzt fertig,
also, wie gesagt, noch richtig bissfest
oder beziehungsweise noch gar nicht durch.
Ich nehme jetzt ein bisschen Nudelwasser raus.
Jetzt die Nudeln abgießen.
Schatz, wink mal!
Ha, ja.
Mittagessenszeit, da hilft jeder mit!
Jede Hand zählt!
So. Jetzt kommen die Nudeln wieder zurück in den Topf.
Jetzt gebe ich hier noch ein bisschen Nudelwasser rein.
Jetzt hier komplett über die Nudeln leeren.
Und die Soße könnt ihr wirklich wunderbar vorbereiten.
Die Nudeln dann wirklich nur
vorkochen.
Und dann kurz vor dem Essen
zusammenschütten.
Und fertig.
Jetzt muss ich sie natürlich noch ein bisschen kochen lassen,
damit die Nudeln jetzt al dente werden.
Dann ist unser Penne Arrabbiata fertig.
Und bei Bedarf
könnt ihr jetzt hier das Nudelwasser noch zugießen,
wenn ihr braucht.
Und dann probieren wir es gleich mit etwas Petersilie bestreut.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist das Essen fertig!
Volkan, du kannst probieren!
Murat, magst du auch probieren?
>> MURAT: Nee, ich spüle ab.
>> SALLY: Nein, jetzt probier doch!
Guck mal, wie lecker das aussieht!
Mmh!
Komm.
Ein bisschen Chili.
>> VOLKAN: Chili.
>> SALLY: Aber das Chili ist scharf!
>> VOLKAN: Ja?
>> SALLY: Das ist Pulver.
Das waren die aus dem Garten.
Esst!
Penne Arrabbiata.
>> >> MURAT: Cool!
>> SALLY: Und, Volkan?
>> VOLKAN: Lecker! Ja, super!
>> MURAT: Tomatig, aber nicht süß. Das ist gut.
>> SALLY: Ja. Volkan und ich, wir lieben Penne Arrabbiata!
>> VOLKAN: Hm. Hm.
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> SALLY: Weil
vor allem, wenn man sich vegan ernährt,
dann ist es schwierig, wenn man essen geht,
weil viele damit noch nichts anfangen können.
Aber im Prinzip
kochen viele schon immer vegan,
wissen es nur nicht.
Also ein superschnelles Gericht!
Im Prinzip ging es hier jetzt auch eher
um den zeitlichen Ablauf.
Denn die Zubereitung ist echt ganz einfach.
Die Zutaten sind super easy.
>> MURAT: Und
>> SALLY: Wir holen jetzt das ganze Team zum Essen.
>> MURAT: ganz wichtig: Die Nudeln nicht verkochen!
>> SALLY: Nicht verkochen!
>> MURAT: Das ist das Schlimmste, was du machen kannst!
00:06:40,500 --> 00:06:40,300
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Wirklich! Das ist dann...
>> SALLY: Und deswegen
wirklich nur die Soße vorbereiten und kochen.
Nudeln dann kurz vor dem Verzehr
fünf Minuten lang kochen lassen,
dann mit dem Nudelwasser,
also nicht komplett,
aber mit etwas Nudelwasser in die Soße geben,
durchziehen lassen,
fertig!
>> VOLKAN: Superlecker!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich mache jetzt auch bei mir noch ein bisschen Chili drauf.
Wir machen den Salat noch kurz fertig.
Und dann essen wir.
Also bis dann!
Tschüss!
>> VOLKAN: Tschau!
>> SALLY: Viel Spaß beim Nachkochen!
Und, wenn ihr weitere einfache Nudelrezepte sehen wollt,
dann schreibt es einfach in die Kommentare.
Oder, was ich als Nächstes machen soll.
[Musik]